ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman so i want to start today with the
vaccination
and the delta variant and some really
really ignorant stuff continuing to come
out of i mean i guess we have to call it
the
at least tacitly anti-vaxx media
um fox hosts on fox and friends
can't understand why president joe biden
is so focused on getting americans
vaccinated and on getting vaccines
to people around the world in other
countries now last week i did a segment
where
i explained i really hate politics
not because i lack passion about the
issues but because so much of our time
has to be spent preventing really
ignorant people
bad people in some cases from actively
doing damage to the country
and here is a perfect example of this
right now we are engaged
in a battle against a virus and a highly
contagious delta variant
and against anti-vaxxers as well to
truly end this pandemic we're not just
fighting the virus
we're fighting the anti-vaxxers as well
the so-called coveted truthers
unfortunately some countries do not yet
have enough vaccines that's a very
specific problem
but just as unfortunately we do have
enough vaccines
but we have a huge portion of our
population in the u.s that just doesn't
want one
and our ability to defeat this pandemic
now comes down
so simply i mean it couldn't be any
simpler
just get vaccinated vaccinate as quickly
as possible
and on fox news their minds are just
boggled by joe biden working
really proactively on vaccination why
won't he stop working on vaccination
take a look at this meanwhile sedman
says at the top of the hour one of the
big stories
been with us the last two years is
covered 19. the origin is the top story
but the but the focus of this
administration on vaccination
is uh mind-boggling listen in many cases
they've done a very good job getting the
word out
and getting the vaccine out from johnson
johnson to pfizer to moderna
they're available if you want them but
that's not enough now you need to be
berated by none other than dr
fauci because you're playing politics
that's the reason
you may have not gotten it listen
this is not complicated we're not asking
anybody to make any political statement
one way or another
we're saying try and save your life and
that of your family and that of the
community
it's mind-boggling guys and look at
brian kilmeade even saying
you know some people might not want to
get vaccinated
because they're being encouraged if you
just left them alone is the implication
maybe they would go and get themselves
vaccinated it's it's like an insanely
childish reverse psychology
to get people vaccinated to save their
own lives or the lives of people they
love or people in their communities you
have to go to the childish
oh you can't have this little jimmy oh
really oh
i want it then give me the thing you're
telling me i can't have
and this is why things are now looking
so rough
i can't believe this is happening but
cases are going way up
here in the united states i i cases are
up almost 50
50 cases are up in the last 10 days
in spain spain really had this under
control
cases are up 360 percent
measures are quickly being put back in
place
in the united kingdom that's one of the
spot's earliest hit by the delta variant
daily cases are up
1400 now of course
the good news depending on your
perspective is that
it's mostly unvaccinated people that are
getting infected right now
now you might say well that's good news
in the sense that it means the vaccines
work well
the problem is not everybody can get
vaccinated yet in some countries because
they don't yet have vaccines in some
countries because they're too young to
qualify
uh but but that's not that's not
everybody right i mean six to eight
percent of people of normal health
will get a vaccine and not develop
immunity and
there are breakthrough cases more and
more of them are the delta variant
and some of those vaccinated people are
going to get hit as well
and in the meantime as cases are up 50
percent in the united states
fox news can't figure out why is so
biden
so focused on vaccination as if it's a
bad thing
we are really in trouble as a country
and i don't expect this to get any
better they seem to be digging in
and forget about delta we're soon going
to have lambda
i don't even want to guess at this point
i'm not even going to think about it yet
what things are going to look like in
the united states in the fall
all right we have to review cpac the
conservative political action conference
hosted by the american conservative
union did
you know they i feel like they just did
cpac in in florida
they did it again in texas this weekend
we are going to go through
uh speeches we are going to go through
attendees we are going to look at the
results of the straw poll
it's just a big cpac day we're getting
all the cpac stuff out of the way
the first thing we're going to start
with is donald trump's
speech that he gave at cpac the big
theme
of the speech was trump telling lies
about the election
and also lots of really weird and
incoherent things
happening so let's just start going
through it we'll start with some of the
weird stuff
in this first clip trump's teeth
sort of chirp it's an unusual thing and
he launches an attack
of course on wind farms his favorite
enemy
and we don't need windmills in texas and
lots of other places
we don't need when they ought to end
that
program as quickly as they can so trump
there continuing his brutal assault on
wind power a completely incoherent one
and uh yeah teeth chirping very
interestingly
trump then uh continuing to sort of
struggle to get certain uh words out
here talking about illegal youth arrives
and arrivals
overall illegal youth arrives
and arrivals are up nearly five yeah
so not only are youth arrivals up but
youth
arrives are also up and then trump
really getting into
i guess what we would sort of call the
meat of the speech which
is uh starting to talk about how we
actually won
and someone yells trump won and the
crowd just absolutely loves it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's true we all won we all won
yeah we all won yeah do we we we did
really
um and then it starts to get more
confusing in this next clip trump
lists things that worked against him
during the election
but he still sort of won but it was like
they cheated but he won anyway
even though not really publicly
announced i mean see if you can follow
this
then without any basis whatsoever
twitter and facebook
banned the new york post's account of
this
terrible story right after the election
one poll showed that at least 10 percent
of joe biden's voters would have
switched their vote
if they had known about joe and hunter
biden scandals
so this is the idea that the the hunter
biden quote scandal
about bringing three laptops across the
country to a blind guy
who's not sure but thinks because of a
sticker that they were probably hunter's
hard drives but you know if that hadn't
been suppressed
by the so-called fake news media trump
would have won enough to flip the
results of numerous states
but he won anyway right that's the so
but he would have won
but he won anyway but don't worry about
it because we won those states anyway
wait a second so did did that make it so
you lost
but or did you actually win it's all
very very confusing and then trump
continued
pushing this and as trump likes to say
if you repeat a lie often enough
people start to see it as the truth and
he continued doing
the vote rigging stuff every time
the media references the election hoax
they say the fraud is unproven true
and while there is no evidence no
evidence
no evidence there's so much evidence you
saw what happened in georgia the other
day they found 35 000
votes then they deleted in georgia
over a hundred thousand votes i said
because they were so
bad voters i said why didn't you try
doing it before the election the voters
were bad so they deleted votes i mean
this is this barely is english lost by
this much why didn't you do it before
the election
there's bad things going on in this
country so continuing to spread this
absolute nonsense trump then moved into
attacking his own former attorney
general bill barr he's actually attacked
bill barr a number of times now
including because barr didn't do enough
to take the election and he didn't go
after democrats enough and very casually
in this segment
trump also misstates what brett
kavanaugh was even accused of
i mean just it's all lies all the way
down said this because i didn't want to
but i will
i'm very disappointed that bill barr was
unable to hold anyone accountable
right for the countless abuses of power
by the democrats
the justice department wasn't operating
at the direction of trump
translated is what that means
he didn't hold the corrupt officials who
spied on our campaign
remember i said they're spying on our
campaign
that's of course another lie that
trump's been repeating for a long time
that was like a lightning rod went off
not the authors of the phony dossier
they weren't held responsible not the
women
who slandered and lied and defamed
brett kavanaugh they said brett
kavanaugh he had an affair
they didn't go after them they lied so
badly now of course brett kavanaugh was
not accused of having an affair he was
accused of sexual assault
and rape and so even misstating what it
was
there this is also another funny thing
check out what donald trump claims
joe biden has done in his short time in
office so far
in a matter of mere months joe biden has
brought
our country to the brink of ruin
[Laughter]
who could possibly believe that and the
answer is the people at cpac and later
we're actually going to be looking at
some of the interviews because remember
if people don't believe this trash
trump's in an empty room yelling at the
wall
the fact that the room is full with
people who believe it is as much a part
of the problem or even a bigger problem
than the fact that trump exists then
trump actually
telling the truth here i don't even
fully get this but trump says
being impeached twice made him even
worse
i don't know what he means but i think
he's actually telling the truth here
i understand that i didn't become
different i got impeached twice
i didn't change i became worse
i became worse okay trump saying
impeachment made him even worse and that
i actually do agree with that's very
true
almost beyond parody they're going back
to the migrant caravans
at any time that it's convenient it's
migrant caravans
thanks to democrats it's like
infrastructure week it's like clockwork
with these guys
we shut down the migrant caravans you
haven't seen those caravans
get ready because they're coming up
right they're back and watching them
come through and in those caravans you
have some
deadly people we you know i have to tell
you
i think trump's disgusting but if trump
if someone
went to him and actually you know
convinced him as he likes to say they
they go to him and they say
sure sure exactly and they go sir
just promote the vaccine just go out
there and promote the vaccine and if
trump went out there
and said guys listen you know how we
cheer because i made the vaccines this
is the lie he tells his supporters
the vaccine i made it's great for you
every single one of my patriotic
supporters
get the patriotic vaccine i got it in
january
i would actually my respect for trump
would go from zero to one or two percent
that would dramatically increase my
respect for the guy
if he took these opportunities and
instead of talking about migrant
caravans
just straight up said get yourselves
vaccinated he's not doing it
instead he's back on the cognitive test
is it very easy for democrats to cheat
and to win elections you don't have too
many of them in texas do you louis huh
dr ronnie do we have the great doc
ronnie my doctor
yeah he became a congressman
right he only beat 22 people
22 people he was great i said doc
how about if i take a cognitive test he
said well you can do it sir but if you
do you know
it'll be public oh i said what's wrong
with that he said well if you don't do
well sir it's not going to be pretty
sir i said is it hard he said after the
first five questions it gets very hard
now we've already debunked that the test
is not difficult i said let's take a
shot at it
and we did it and we aced it right i
aced it
again these crowds cheering that trump
didn't
fail a test for serious advanced
dementia
that's now an applause line
[Applause]
and one of the doctors said he's never
seen anybody that aced it
and some of those sir no one's aced this
test before you have the littlest amount
of dementia of anyone we've ever looked
at
questions are not easy i will tell you
that tough stuff
how do you think joe would do in our
cognitive
all right so anyway there's trump back
on the cognitive test he's still talking
about hillary clinton by the way and
when he does
the crowd predictably starts chanting
lock her up lock up they're for law and
order and due process they say lock up
people not even
charged with crime crooked hillary
clinton
who by the way is the most angry person
in the united states today she's gone
away
you know why she said why the hell
didn't you do that
for me in 2016.
forget it there are more people than her
so going with the locker up stuff
trump here saying the quiet part out
loud about
polling this is funny because we knew
this was what was what he was doing
and he's saying it to his supporters by
the way you have a poll coming out
unfortunately i want to know what it is
they you know they do that straw poll
right
now if it's bad i just saw i say it it's
fake
right if it's good
i say that's the most accurate poll
perhaps ever
that we we knew that's what he was doing
and yet his supporters laugh
but he's telling you the truth guys
that's the truth about trump's view on
polling
and then lastly um capping the speech
with more lies
about the election and this will be a
big piece of 2022
and 2024. we will never give up our
search for truth
and justice for what happened in the
corrupt presidential election of 2020
because
without that truth we cannot have an
honest election
all that happened is he lost 2022 or
2024 no matter
what they want to tell you
and our country will soon stand
proudly for free and strong
and proper elections now of course we
mostly have them already
aside from some irregularities the real
election fraud is the voter suppression
that takes place
so a completely deranged speech we'll
look at some interviews with attendees
we will look at the straw poll we're
going to look at everything today as
well as some other things
we are now gearing up for the 16th
anniversary of the david pakman show
on august 16th it will be the 16th
anniversary of the show
and we are going to be doing a
membership blowout the likes of which no
doctors have ever even heard
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then on august 16th
you will get
something very special in your email and
a great opportunity to get a heavily
heavily discounted membership let me
know your thoughts about the trump
speech
you can find me on twitter at dpakman
and we'll be right back
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back
ground news is one of the first things i
would use
to get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform
that lets you compare how outlets from
the left right and center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story
and it also shows you your news blind
spots stories that your side of the
political spectrum
may not have covered ground news can
help you build a well-crafted argument
for debating people you disagree with
or ground news can help you discover
something new
about your own perspective challenging
your own strongly held views on
political issues
be the most informed person in the room
download the free ground news app today
by going to ground.news
pacman remember that the best way
to support our work is to get a
membership at joinpackman.com i
encourage you to do it why not today
today is as great a day as any
let's continue our coverage of cpac next
i want to look
at a donald trump jr speech and then
we're going to look at some interviews
with attendees
and i have some bigger picture thoughts
about cpac which i'll tell you
in a moment earlier in the weekend
donald trump jr
spoke and everything from even just how
he was introduced
to what he said to the strange applause
lines to an interview
he gave it's all really horrifying stuff
but in the straw poll that was conducted
and announced at the end of cpac
other than donald trump uh don jr was
actually i believe
third in terms of 2024 presidential
candidates this is not a guy who should
be ignored this is a guy who
has a lot of the same terrible instincts
of donald trump but is far more
competent and a far better
speaker so let's get right into it here
is don jr being introduced introduced by
his girlfriend
uh former fox news host kimberly
guilfoyle it's all like just cult of
personality type stuff
please join me in welcoming a true
warrior
and the embodiment of america first
movement
donald trump jr
[Applause]
weird skip
yeah so you get the idea but just
complete cult of personality
uh there's a very kind of totalitarian
authoritarian you know uh uh
cult stuff that continues to happen at
these events
and um i mean just to give you a sense
of it
here in this next clip you'll sort of
hear a crowd member yell
trump one during junior's speech and he
lets them cheer for a full minute i mean
it's a
it's a level of sort of like um deistic
idolatry
that should scare all of us because of
how divorced from reality it is
[Music]
there it was
[Music]
they're just cheering for trump one
that's a defiant and an
inspirational thing to say at this event
yeah so you get the idea of what
cheering for lies sounds like
then there's a really strange moment
where i
he seemed to lose his ability to speak
coherently for a moment
said something weird about texas and
then kind of looked around
i still don't understand this moment but
take a listen to it
texas has always led the charge
well till about like a couple months ago
and then austin sort of took over like i
don't know guys like texas was leading
the chart
you're still top 25.
but we got to work on that stuff because
those people have lost their minds huh
right
so very strange you know you may want to
save the anti-texas material for when
cpac is in a state other than texas don
i don't know i'm not
an expert on this type of thing but a
very very strange moment
and um then things just continue to get
weird i don't
let's just even take a look at this next
one i'm not even sure what we're gonna
see here
can't allow it to happen we need to push
back
oh okay so there's the trump one thing
and then let's skip ahead when he goes
back to speaking
i guess he's the most popular president
ever he's significantly more popular
than barack obama was in 08 especially
in the inner cities because he has a
track record of not being racist
his son definitely didn't drop
let's say words that i don't even want
to use abbreviations for with letters in
them
so then he really goes into the hunter
biden stuff
and i've been saying for a while this is
a party that it
they're off of issues they're not doing
any political issue stuff anymore it's
stop communism which you'll see in the
interviews with the with the attendees
it's stopped joe biden joe biden has
dementia
uh they're undoing everything trump did
and they're redoing things obama did
and then he really goes in on hunter
biden and calls them
a piece of garbage i say that they say
oh you're making fun of people with
addiction i go
let's just talk about this for a second
i totally understand addiction it's
terrible
we all know people that have suffered
from it it doesn't absolve you from
being a total piece of garbage in every
other aspect of your life
this used to be an event at which
they did talk about policy policy i
didn't agree with
policy i found to be completely immoral
and disgusting
but the president's son is a piece of
trash
is now what they're doing here's one
last clip here's don jr being
interviewed before or after his speech
and uh it's very clear he's going to be
as involved as trump
in 22. i'm going to be very involved the
reality is you know i'm the father of
five young kids i'm a patriotic american
i love this country and i look at what's
going on
and someone has to push back you know
there's not many people that have sort
of the privilege of having a big
platform there's not many people who
have a big platform that are actually
willing to use it
to sort of go against the mainstream
narrative i think the facts are on my
sides and it's a battle we have to have
so i'm happy to do it it's an honor
i'm telling you guys this is a guy who
if he gets the
oxygen trump got in you know 10 years
as as of right now we have a country
that would elect don junior president
and he's far more competent than donald
trump i think the left
should actually be scared uh because the
the right has proven they
they will elect anybody and if trump can
get elected
i think don jr can get elected as well
it's scary stuff let's now talk about
the trump supporters
so i'm going to play some videos for you
of interviews
with cpac attendees trump supporters
at the texas cpac conference that took
place
over the weekend remember why do we care
about the attendees
without supporters the current
republican movement which is trumpism
would just be trump in a room yelling
and there would nobody there would be
nobody there
so you have to understand that the
attendees
give us insight into why trump was even
able to win okay so let's get right into
it let's get into
uh some of these uh very very strange
interviews here we go
they should pay attention to their
children and what they say when they
come home from school
don't criticize listen if there's things
that go against
what they've been teaching their
children then they need to go to a
school board meeting
we all need okay so understand that this
is why republicans win
okay these are people
at the conference and as wacky as their
beliefs are
they understand the way to win is you
get involved at your local school board
now i'm not saying democrats don't get
involved at the local school board but
what i am saying
is republicans have been so much better
than democrats for so long
at working at all of these levels really
strongly
they control all sorts of state and
local boards of education
that's how they get this crazy nonsense
in school and into classrooms
they they do know what they're doing in
that sense in a way that i've not seen
uh democrats do well let's listen to
some more
the books that our kids are being forced
to read so that we can have an honest
conversation with
right there's a way to fight back and
the way to do it is use your words and
use your money
go to your schools don't send your kid
to an indoctrination camp on college
use your money email the alumni of the
schools
email the donors say this is what
they're teaching my kids in school
i think the way we can combat it is by
parents really knowing what's being
taught
in the schools i don't know that passing
laws do
any good at all generally a lot of the
laws that are passed are either ignored
or creates anger but we have to get rid
of the critical theory
being on school boards uh getting into
elected offices
so that you know what the curriculum is
that is being taught
this is how they have successfully done
what democrats have been unable to do
for a really long time so that's one
side of cpac this is like the old school
cpac
these people actually do know how to
organize in the real world online stuff
they're actually terrible
they really are terrible with the online
stuff but they know exactly what they're
doing there now
here is the cartoonish side here are
some interviews
right side broadcasting network did this
is the other side
and the wacky people that show up let's
take a look here hey how you doing
hey mike mike with right side yeah so
latinos for
trump right so talk about latinos for
trump what do you think president
trump's going to be saying here you have
a trump
2024 shirt i think he's going to be
running here absolutely i think so
yes what do you think his message is
going to surround today what do you want
to hear him say the most besides that
he's running
um that we are not going to let our
country fall to communism
i was very excited when that is that
listen we've been covering this for for
months for years this is what the
republican party now is what she wants
to hear from trump it's not about
how am i going to put money in your
pocket how am i going to get you health
care
how are we going to fix infrastructure
it's um
how are we going to stop communism
there's no threat of communism in the
united states
there's no there's no risk that the
united states will become a communist
country
their messaging is nuts but
these people seem to have accepted it
hook line and sinker
um president trump started talking about
socialism
because no one was having that
conversation even though we were seeing
it happen
in all of our communities wow no one was
having that conversation
they didn't want to say call it what it
is it's communism
then we have a lot what's communism what
is communism
organizations here in the state of texas
that our
um like our people's project or texas
organizing project
it sounds you know the way they word it
you know but it's it's worded in such a
way where
you wouldn't say or think that that is a
communist org and they are running
communists
on the democratic ballot here in the
state of texas so
this woman's completely wrong about the
facts of everything that's going on
but it's been very very effective and
they don't care about policy so when we
say oh
at some point don't they have to get
back to policy
not really because if they can just go
with
fear of communism that doesn't exist
they don't really need to go back to
that
here's another example next person they
interviewed of
they understand the importance of going
local thank you jen appreciate it
what uh sure sure what are you yeah
i am from california and i'm an activist
and uh i believe in what we're saying
here about getting involved and stuff
but i think we forget to mention that
how we're going to do that we need to
get back into the neighborhoods
we need to do in california right now we
are organizing
uh precincts and voter registration yeah
i'm not talking about voter registration
i i think that's actually that's a great
point i'm glad you can they get it
guys they get it and so as cartoonish as
these people
are the they can keep winning stuff
they can keep what they the local uh
element here
they get it here's one more here's a
homeschooler that they ran into
and you brought your daughter along so
so karen talk about your experience
feedback
why are you here what did you hope to
get out of it and we're towards the end
now so what are your final thoughts
well i'm absolutely blown away i mean
this this is our first cpac
and i decided to bring i'm a homeschool
mom so i i homeschool my three kids
and so this is basically part of their
education right now homeschooling
okay the most common reason that people
homeschool in the u.s
is because they want a safe school
environment that's 25
now what does that mean they're not
talking about physical safety
when they mean safe they mean safe from
indoctrination that they believe is
taking place that's 25 percent of
homeschoolers
say that's why they're homeschooling 21
of homeschoolers are
doing it to teach kids their religious
and moral views
these are overwhelmingly conservative
christians okay that's the homeschooling
movement
that's the element there's huge overlap
between the christian homeschoolers
and the anti-vaxxers there's huge
overlap between the christian
homeschoolers
and the right wing conspiracy theory so
right away hitting all the highlights
of these folks let's continue but i
brought charlotte she's 14 with me
it's it's been amazing i mean i'm
meeting so many great people i feel at
home
finally i'm from california so it's a
little tough
right there sometimes that's why she
homeschools she's because she wants her
daughter around people
like the ones that go to cpac but um and
i appreciate you guys so much for all
you do we actually
can find the rallies and we can find all
the the true news here so it's been
wonderful
so so and charlotte so you are
14 years old right and this is probably
your first political event
right so so what what your thoughts been
on the last couple days it's been insane
it's been pretty overwhelming but it's
been really cool
like seeing everyone and meeting
everyone i especially liked when trump
had people chant
lock her up about hillary so who who who
is your favorite person that you've met
have you met any
congresspeople politicians when lauren
bobert said no vaccines i thought that
was so proud
i was so proud of that it was so great
meeting anybody like that we met matt
and mercedes schlapp
really kind to us it was really cool to
meet them amazing like i said earlier
the great thing about cpac
is that grassroots people people who
just love this country so there it is
really horrifying stuff at cpac but
these people
vote they won in 2016 they almost won in
2020 and we have a
really big uphill battle in 2022 and
2024 upcoming
after the break we'll talk about the
cpac straw poll winner
uh and a bunch of other stuff we'll have
more on this
on the show's instagram find it david
pakman show
on instagram oh by the way follow me i
showed people my eggplant over the
weekend on my instagram david.pakman
it's my first eggplant
and you can find that on my my instagram
quick break back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive of every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com and use the coupon code
better21 for a huge discount
join pacman.com okay so we're winding
down
our cpac coverage we'll talk a little
bit more about it at the end of the show
but
uh the the sort of important thing that
comes out of cpac the conservative
political action conference
every year we get closer to an election
it becomes more relevant
is the cpac straw poll where attendees
vote
as to who they uh would like to see or
approve of
in terms of the next presidential
nominee and as it turns out donald trump
is still
very much in control of the republican
party
cnn report trump wins cpac straw poll
as attendees clamor for him to run again
former president donald trump bathed in
the adulation of an adoring crowd
at cpac sunday as he easily won the
informal straw poll of attendees
when they were asked who they'd like to
see run for the white house in
2024 let's go to a video
of cpac announcing the results when
trump
is included and the results when trump
is not included
take a look at this first one we're
gonna do is without donald trump this is
the
scenario where he says no i'm not gonna
run well tell us what it looks like
fellas go ahead ryan
ron desantis 68
secretary pompeo at five and donald
trump junior four
and now let's take a look at what it
looks like when donald trump
is in the race for 2024. are we ready
70 percent
it was not 21
[Applause]
go ahead all right and finally we asked
an approval question of donald trump
across the conference there was very
very little disagreement
with the 98 approval rating for donald
trump
okay so really no big surprise there
we were of the impression that trump was
still completely in control of the
republican party
and he clearly seems to be when you
include him
he easily wins the straw poll how much
of that is people who are just excited
by his celebrity and trump being there
yeah maybe to some degree there are some
of them the other
steady component is that ron desantis
seems to be
very clearly out ahead of the rest of
the pack as a possible
second place contender someone who i
mean listen
if he tried to fight trump for the
nomination i don't know what would
happen because much of a desantis
support
comes from the fact that he is seen as
trump adjacent and that donald trump has
generally been very supportive of ron
desantis
if donald trump didn't run and
particularly if trump didn't run and
said
support ron desantis the numbers right
now to me suggest
ron desantis would be a pretty clear
favorite
um if it's not trump for the 2024
republican nomination now as i've said
before i think this is extraordinarily
dangerous
why is it dangerous as i've said before
if you say
assume that the president will be a
republican
who would you like it to be and in those
cases
i've typically said well if it has to be
a republican
i would lean towards somebody like mitt
romney mitt romney's no great guy i
don't agree with him about a bunch of
stuff
but he's at least sort of like on this
planet and i know people will say david
oh what are you talking about romney's
horrible yeah romney's horrible but
if the question is romney or trump i'm
going with romney or in the past i would
say well
somebody like john mccain as an example
um you know previously some people won't
like this but
like william f buckley okay will some
bunch of william f buckley's foreign
policy
is is horrible but william f buckley
versus trump what
one of them is a thinker at least okay
and we won't agree
on a lot of stuff but that that would be
if you said it's got to be a republican
that's the line
i'm thinking of desantis is very much in
the trumpian wing
completely cartoonish opened everything
like months into the pandemic and
florida has just been a complete and
total mess now florida's seeing
again some of the highest rates they
just don't do anything i was just there
it was crazy anti-vaxxer told me
their mom became magnetized from getting
the vaccine
desantis is completely bonkers but
he's more competent than trump
significantly more competent than trump
and so when we look at you know i
already said
if it's trump biden i think biden's in
trouble
if it's trump harris i think kamala's in
trouble
uh the other side of this is well
if it's desantis instead of trump if
desantis can spend the next couple of
years
building name recognition he is
far more competent in that evil genius
sort of way
than is donald trump and i would be very
concerned
about uh about about ron desantis but
for now
trump remains in control of the
republican party clearly the favorite
and we're going to continue following
how those numbers change as we get into
in particular
you know when we get into the midterms
and that's starting soon
we're four months from the start of the
midterms basically
um if trump's picks don't do well in
2022
that could really weaken trump and we're
going to wait and see what happens on
that
one of the most popular sort of punching
bags for conservatives right now is the
state of california
they love to say california is a liberal
hellhole
california is what happens when the
left-wing policies of democrats
run rampant but the truth is that that's
bogus and a few weeks ago i did a story
called
so-called failed state of california
sets
economic growth record and in that story
i went through the economic data and it
turns out california is actually doing
really well economic growth is some of
the highest in the u.s in california
the economic surplus in california the
budget surplus is at a record level
so those claims about california
throughout the pandemic have been false
another talking point is people are
fleeing california everybody's leaving
california
it's going to be left empty the
cupboards will be bare of people
as trump likes to say we now have a new
study about that
and it is also just a lie republicans
want to paint california as a place that
people are just
desperate to get out of they'll go
anywhere they'll just get me out of
california
and it never passed the sniff test
because
if people really were getting out their
magical perfect rational market
would lead to a significant drop in the
cost of living in california basic
supply and demand
rents would go down property values
would go down that's not happening
but putting the sniff test aside there's
a new study from the university of
california system
which found that the number of people
moving out of california to other states
is up slightly compared to 2012 but it's
at very similar numbers to what we saw
throughout the mid and late 2000s there
are some people moving out as people
move out move out of any state
but at historically sort of normal
levels meanwhile there are still young
people
moving into california at relatively
high rates they're also going other
places some of them are going to texas
some of them are going to colorado
you do see some older folks moving out
of california
but it's really no big deal the
percentage of californians who plan to
leave the state
when you ask them has remained basically
the same over the last two years
23 of california california voters say i
am seriously considering leaving the
state
that was 24 2 years ago basically the
same
that sounds huge and obviously if a
quarter of california left california
it would be a cataclysm economically but
remember that most people who say
they're considering leaving don't i mean
like
i've been considering moving to miami
for five years and then i realize
i don't really know anybody there i'd be
far from my family
i'm gonna stay put at least for now but
like if you ask me at many points
i i would consider leaving and going to
florida sure yeah
that's something i've considered i'm not
really going to do it and that's for
most people
one interesting thing is that there's a
big partisan gap though on that question
if you ask democrats 21 say i'm
considering leaving california if you
ask republicans
30 say i'm considering leaving
california no surprise
politically it's very and vogue right
now to say
you're thinking of leaving california
any guys
i'll do it don't make me because i'm
just one day from
renting a u-haul and getting out of here
most people don't do it
and it's important to remember that if
people did leave california in large
numbers
the heroic perfect market that the
republicans love to harp on would lead
to lower prices
that's what republicans claim is the
problem in california they say prices
are too high
a real estate costs too much rent is too
damn high
that's caused by demand there's a reason
it's more expensive to live in san
francisco than it is to live in
you know tulsa oklahoma no offense to
oklahoma
education is better in california
there are higher salaries in california
than in oklahoma there's more access to
culture there's more access to airports
with direct flights to the rest of the
world
there's a higher standard of healthcare
there's better infrastructure it
demand drives prices up doesn't mean
people in oklahoma are bad people
it's just the market that these
right-wingers point to that's why it's
expensive to be in california
but right-wingers just feel like
everybody's leaving california
so do we pay attention to facts or do we
pay attention to feelings i forget how
that statement goes
over time people may leave california
who knows but it's just not happening
right now
to any significant degree california is
not failing economically
and people are not fleeing california
that's the truth it may change in the
future
but it's not happening right now
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
alright so let's take a look at some of
the delusions that were taking place at
cpac this weekend now
really understand that cpac the
conservative political action conference
put on by the american conservative
union
it used to be mostly like a pretty
standard republican event
you know they would say things i
disagreed with about taxes
uh i wouldn't agree with them on health
care i wouldn't agree with them about
abortion i wouldn't agree about gay
marriage or foreign policy
but it wasn't always a totally nuts
q anon conspiracy type event
cpac appears to now have completely
surrendered
to the most extreme conspiratorial
unhinged elements of the party
essentially like the wackiest of the
pro-trump wing
of the republican party and hilariously
a seven-point plan to reinstate donald
trump
in days rather than years yeah
was handed out at cpac um this
you have to see and interestingly it
does include one point from our story a
few weeks ago
the idea of trump becoming uh
speaker of the house andrew solinder
from forbes tweeted about this
cpac attendees sent me this picture of a
card they were handed
about a seven point plan to restore
donald j
trump in days not years which involves
installing trump as
speaker and ousting biden and
harris so let's look at the plan point
one by the
notice that the first point is
meaningless the first point is
reveal achilles heel pull back the
curtain on the horror show
that is today's democrat party watch
pelosi melt like the wicked witch of the
west
see the black caucus and other key
groups
flip unexpectedly and watch the tables
turn
fraud the second that one's meaningless
okay
the second item just means they want to
win the next election that's not it's
not really a plan it's sort of like
what political parties do uh number two
is witness a trusted conservative
elected a speaker of the house and
finally
reveal suppressed results of existing
investigations into election
racketeering the second part won't
happen
because they just lost but the first
part is like just win
then they want to correct the official
record and reveal that trump
legitimately won the 2020 election
their fourth part is that the speaker of
the house will draft articles of
impeachment for biden harris
that we know that that's what they want
to do if they win the house in 22
then they will uh elect trump speaker of
the house now remember we talked about
this some weeks ago
you actually don't have to be a member
of congress to be speaker of the house
traditionally that's the case that's the
way it's been but trump could be made
speaker
without even being a member of congress
then they would have
the speaker of the house trump call for
a vote to impeach
charge and remove biden and harris who
they refer to as imposters
and then step seven is duly impeach
charge and remove biden and harris
which you know seems very similar to
item number six
so what's funny is that really the only
two
things here that are a plan would be
item number two which is to win the next
election
and in order to do that one way to do it
would be hey come up with some
substantive policy ideas like win
by offering policy that people like
no they're not doing that uh instead
they're going with option two
which is try to suppress the vote to win
and only talk about things like
communism
and critical race theory or whatever
else they are trying to do that
it didn't work in 2020 they didn't
suppress enough of the vote in 2020
but they came kind of close and so we
have to really
i don't know why i am really worried
about 22 and 24 more than i've been
this far in advance of any recent
election
i think we have to be ready that they
they almost suppressed enough of the
vote
they may do it in 22 and they may do it
in 24.
all right speaking of 2024 um in
addition to speaking at cpac donald
trump gave an absolutely absurd
interview
to fox news's maria bartoromo she will
not
question anything trump says he can get
away with anything he could say maria
you're now you know whatever he he she
will not question anything uh that
donald trump says
and during this interview trump seems to
say he's running in 2024. we'll get to
that
and also effectively claimed that the
death of a january 6 trump rioter named
ashley babbitt
was essentially a political
assassination by a democratic staffer
this is truly dangerous stuff let's get
into it
well that's right and i want to talk
about that because ashley babbitt a
wonderful woman
fatally shot on january 6 as she tried
to climb out
now notice normally when people are
killed by police
people like maria and trump defend the
police they say
don't break the law then you won't get
shot this woman
this wonderful woman uh the the
she she was there illegally right she
was trespassing and if the situation was
reversed they'd be saying
why was she even there of a broken
window
her family has spoken out her family has
been on tucker carlson
and they want answers as far as why this
wonderful woman
young woman who went to peaceful protest
was shot
is anything true a piece she was she she
was there
criminally and it was not a peaceful
protest it it's terrible that she died
it's absolutely terrible but this is
revisionist history guys
any information there is speculation
that this was a
security detail in a leading member of
congress's
uh security detail a democrat what can
you tell us
in terms of who shot ashley babbitt what
do you know mr president
so i've heard that i will tell you they
know who shot ashley babbitt
they're protecting that person i've
heard also that it was the head of
security for a certain
high official a democrat and
we'll see because conspiracies
conspiracies
about what took place and where is the
support of the police
normally they're all about support the
police and then maria bartoromo strongly
suggests
that it was a chuck schumer staffer who
shot and killed
ashley babbitt i i have no idea could
that possibly be true i don't know
but the speculation is very
irresponsible
yeah it's absolutely quite extraordinary
i want you to know that
my team reached out to senator chuck
schumer's office
to check on what he may know about who
shot
ashley babbitt we have not heard back
from chuck schumer's office
we did send a note and call
yeah what do you think do you know who
it is mr president
i wonder why you know they they talk big
and they're
uh real law and order people when it
comes to a certain group
but with another group they can do
whatever they want one of the most
irresponsible interviews i could imagine
and this continues
here is more of this innocent beautiful
wonderful woman stuff
yeah that report showed fbi operatives
uh potentially uh aware
but there are unanswered questions here
what did the fbi know
why weren't your cabinet secretaries
briefed what did
speaker pelosi know chuck schumer
mcconnell
do you have any answers to that they
continue to how much
of a look at the gaslighting
trump instigated the riots and she's
interviewing trump
but it's all about what was pelosi's
role
what was chuck schumer's what are you
talking about
all this stuff and yet no guns were
seized mr president
right there were no guns whatsoever and
yet antifa
which went into portland and went into
so many other places seattle
they took over a big part of seattle
people died
and there were plenty of guns there by
the way and in minnesota in minneapolis
now in fact there were stun guns seized
baseball bats
flag poles being wielded as clubs even
against police
pipe bombs were planted pepper spray
and on and on and on here
is more of trump rewriting history
on the january 6th riots i mean look at
look at what is taking place in this
country
mr president you just referred to the
2020 election i want to refer you to an
article in the federalist
over the weekend and it says new
evidence indicates enough
illegal votes in georgia to tip the 2020
results this is from the federalists
i want to get your thoughts on what's
taking place right now in arizona and
in georgia with regard to that as what's
going on is nothing
but they're calling them audits continue
to post and discuss
election 2020. that's right well the
federalists
they have 35 000 votes and that's far
more
numerous times more than numerous we
need to win that state
yeah so trump continuing with that stuff
um and then going directly from
rewriting the election
to rewriting what happened on january 6.
then remember maria has the guy who
instigated it here
won't ask about that president let me
move on
the fencing around the capitol is
beginning to come down
this week and this weekend and i know
that you have had some time to reflect
on what took place on that day january
6th
talk to us about what you're thinking
about as you reflect
what happened that day from your
standpoint so there was a big rally
called
and actually when i say big who knew but
there was a
rally called and a tremendous number of
people the largest
one i've ever spoken before is called by
people by patriots
notice every rally he's spoken at is
like the
the one that's been most attended in
history every rally
and they asked me if i'd speak and i did
and it was
a very mild-mannered speech i think has
been in fact they just came out with a
report in congress and they didn't
mention my name
that's untrue that report mentions him
dozens of times surely
but what they were complaining about and
the reason
in my opinion you had over a million
people there which the press doesn't
like to report
at all because it shows there were not a
million people there
too much uh too much activity too much
too much uh spirit and faith and love
there was such love at that rally
you had over a million people there they
were you didn't have a million people
there
for one reason the rigged election they
felt the election
was rigged that's why they were there
and they were peaceful people these were
great people so trump completely
gaslighting saying his speech was
totally mild well you told them to go
and they did exactly what you said
he says they were there for a legitimate
reason which is the election was stolen
which
it wasn't and he says that they were
peaceful there were hundreds of people
known to be committing crimes and some
unknown that are still being looked at
okay real quick two last things and one
of them is trump on 2024 here's trump
lamenting that the supreme court didn't
steal the election for him
so this was a terrible blot on our
country and our country's history and
our country
as a you know free and fair place this
you can't allow this to happen we were
very disappointed by the supreme court
because they didn't have the courage to
take it up they couldn't
give you the presidency and he's mad at
pence he's mad at bar he's met at the
supreme court
he simply lost and he can't accept it
now here's the last thing trump on 2024
i think he's saying he's running guys
from what i'm hearing here republicans
against
any democrat they want to do anything
they can to stop that
these are dirty players and it shouldn't
happen it's a disgrace
all right so the question is will you
make the run again
you said that you know your answer but
you're not revealing it yet
you ready to get back in that ring and
run for president again sir
sir i do know my answer but i can't
reveal it yet
and because that has to do with campaign
financing and everything else
you know that so i can't reveal it yet
but i absolutely know my answer
and we're going to do very well people
are going to be very happy
uh and look you know i look at cable
ratings i look at the ratings of cnn to
downtown all right so he says
we're gonna do very well and people are
going to be very happy i think he's
saying that he's running now he may be
lying
he may just be saying it to continue the
grifting to continue raising money but
trump seems to be saying
he is running in 2024 another bizarre
unhinged interview and hugely
irresponsible
hey um here's a caller who is trying to
make me feel shame
about the size of my subscriber base
2192 david p is the number
take a listen to this hey dave your show
is so pathetic 970 subscribers
now this is not a boston accent there's
a rhode island accent it's sort of like
the boston accent's little brother
important to distinguish just from the
standpoint of geography
uh but what is this 970 subscribers
what's he talking about
my god i don't know how you get the
balls to be so freaking stupid
that balls yeah yeah you got more
subscribers inviting spiders got poets
unbelievable you suck so bad i'm only
watching you because
uh youtube shut them down anybody know
what unearthed that guy is talking about
900 subscribers we have over nine
thousand we actually we have one point
uh what do we have 1.3
1.4 million on youtube anyway that's our
friend from rhode island appreciate you
tuning in we've got a great bonus show
today we'll talk about rent prices
soaring as people are going back to
cities
we'll talk about a safe consumption site
the first in the u.s
and a really unusual decision by a court
relating to fda approval
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
ground news is combating divisiveness
in media ground is a news comparison
platform
that helps you see multiple perspectives
for any news story
so you can be more of a well-rounded
news reader
download the free app at ground.news
pacman